The ENTIRE Life Of Pochita/Chainsaw Man
Hey everyone Diavolo here and in todays banger
we are diving back into Chainsaw man and going
over the full life or at least all the info
we have about the TRUE Chainsaw Man better
known to us as just Pochita and his journey
throughout the series.
(SPOILER WARNING) So if you are new around
here and want to see other videos just like
this then make sure you hit that subscribe
button and also be sure to leave a like if
you do enjoy the video as it really helps
out with pushing my content to a bunch of
new
amazing people.
So this here with our teddy bear Pochita isn't
going to be as straight forward as my normal
videos, because the series is through Denji’s
POV Much of Pochita's past is shrouded in
mystery, with the little information throughout
the first 80% of the story being provided
by Makima and other devils our melon loving
boy annihilates.
Before the series even began and something
we don't know for a while but actually see
when Denji first meets him, Pochita was stuck
in a hugely outnumbered and After disappearing
from his battle with some people who ill get
to in a second, Pochita is reduced to a “near-death
state”.
In this state, he appears to be a small orange
doggo like devil with a chainsaw appendage
protruding from the centre of his head almost
like a nose.
Before he was reduced back to the form we
know him as now he was a freaking massive
bulked up, humanoid like devil with four arms
that had these long ass saws protruding from
each, with another chainsaw coming from the
front of his head, similar to Denji's hybrid
form.
SOO think of this when every im referring
to Pochita in the past.
Pochita I guess ever since chainsaws were
invented or maybe even eternity its not really
ever told when he came into existence BUT
he was known as the Chainsaw Man in hell.
The source of his fear stemmed from this series
breaking unique ability of his which erases
devils completely from existence and the memory
of everyone and everything by simply munching
them back.
Devils killed in this form cannot continues
their reincarnation cycle which for anyone
who doesn't know when a devil dies on earth
they return to hell and then when they die
in hell they come back to earth n so on until
Pochita is like nah bro time for a meal, that's
like a suuuper simplified version of it.
OBVIOUSLY this makes Chainsaw Man a massive
threat to devil-kind and earned him the moniker
of "The Devil that Devils fear the most" or
"The Hero of Hell" depending which side your
on.
This infamy made Pochita the target of a many
devils who tried killing him multiple times,
but he always found a way to come back and
fight again.
His power was a subject of worship for some,
making certain devils follow him like beam,
and the object of fear for others, who ran
away trying to escape him.
This eventually culminated in a battle between
him, the Four Horsemen and the Weapon Devils
in which he was badly wounded and, according
to Makima, reduced to a "completely changed
near death form", which like I explained just
before is thought to be his dog form.
At the height of the battle, Pochita vanished,
then was somehow found by Denji on earth.
How he travelled from hell to earth also isn't
even revealed yet, like we don't exactly know
how Pochita managed to travel between the
two worlds.
After what happened at Denji’s fathers Grave,
Pochita who cant communicate and can only
seeming bark like a pup, saw that Denji in
an act of empathy, offered him his blood so
that he could recover from his wounds BUT
only on the condition that the two would become
future partners.
Throughout the few years they spent together
from the time Denji was a child till the current
time period.
Pochita would live alongside him in his leaky
shed listening to Denji and all his worries,
all of his wishes, the food he wanted to eat
and pretty much just everything the two didnt
have in life, while at the same time assisting
him in devil hunting, wood clearing and just
sharing on whatever rations the broke duo
could afford.
One day after Pochita witnesses Denji cough
up blood both of them are called out on a
mission to take down a Devil by that old Yakuza
dude.
Yet Denji is sadly duped by this old fart
who ended up forming his own contract with
the Zombie Devil.
After a short and absolutely terrifying struggle
to escape both Denji and Pochita are mortally
wounded by the hundred or so Yakuza-turned-zombies.
After the pair are just left like garbage
in a dumpster, the blood from Denji somehow
thru pure manga luck managed to flow down
and entered Denji's body.
While going over all of the happy moments
that made up their friendship, he remembers
a specific moment where Denji told him that
if he ever died, to then take over his body
and make his dreams come true for him.
Coming back to reality Pochita begins morphing
shape and assumes the role of Denji’s heart
merging with his torso while also repairing
his damaged body in the process.
Back in the dream world, In a role reversal
Uno reverse card play, Pochita this time manages
to save Denji, but unlike how Denji wanted
him to take over his body and mind he didnt,
instead he communicates with him that he’s
always loved listening to Denji talk about
his dreams.
Due to of this he explains that he wants to
hear more from him he forms a contract with
Denji where he will become his heart and in
return Denji will show him all of his dreams.
Throughout the story Pochita's past as the
Chainsaw Man is briefly alluded to only a
few times before the later arcs.
During the extremely long and drawn out battle
with the Eternity Devil where the main part
of the 4th special division is trapped in
an almost separate time and space unable to
escape.
There ,Denji notices that the Devil is mysteriously
afraid of his chainsaws, doing his best to
avoid any kind of direct confrontation with
him and instead asking for Denji's colleagues
to kill the boy instead.
*ch18 pg12
Yet just to be super difficult the Devil also
seems overjoyed by the fact that it would
be the one to kill the Chainsaw Devil.
Im assuming because of this he would in someway
get a huge powerup thru killing him, obviously
he’s not a fan of the chainsaw man and if
he did actually manage to get the kill all
of the fear the devils have towards the Chainsaw
Devil would probably swap over and increase
the eternity devils power even more.
PLUS id say he’d be contacted by higher
up devils, like the Four Horsemen or maybe
even the primal devils if they hate Pochita
just as much aswell.
After a few days of contemplation over what
to do and everyone's favorite Kobeni tryna
merc Denji with her kitchen knife, he finally
does decide to leave their room and face it
head on.
Once they enter the standoff the Eternity
screams about how the Chainsaw Devil or Pochita
was indeed still alive after all, and that
Denji is far weaker than how Pochita was in
the past.
Once the fight reaches its end in that usual
Tatsuki way where Denji manages to fuel himself
off the enemy's body like some sort of organic
devil reactor that runs off blood.
WHICH is actually massive when you think about
the importance that power or the blood feign
ends up playing later in the story with Pochita
in a similar dumpster to that of the one I
mentioned at the beginning.
Anywaysss back to the story, Himeno like everyone
else heard the taunts and mentions of the
chainsaw devil thru Eternity and later ponders
to Aki why the Eternity devil talked like
he knew about Denji or the Devil inside of
him.
Obviously Himeno herself doesn't fully understand
what Denji is, like I don't think she realizes
Denji has merged with a Devil and that's why
it always referred to Denji’s heart specifically.
As i've said because this video is somewhat
thru Pochita’s POV or the stuff that relates
to him directly and his overall goal with
Denji, we skip way ahead in the story to a
point throughout the bomb girl arc where we
meet the first known hardcore fan of the chainsaw
devil and a personal favorite character of
mine.
After the events of the previous battle
Makima tells Denji that she will have to borrow
Power for an blood extraction as she sucked
on one to many zombies and is having a power
trip currently.
In her place for the time being, she introduces
him to Beam, a shark fiend obsessed with Denji's
chainsaw's powers.
After getting smothered all over by beam,
a hella confused Denji kicks him back off
him and asks Makima why in the world does
Beam have such a devotion towards him, to
which she puts on this super like Ahhh idk
face and tells him that maybe its the resemblance.
Before Denji can prod more though he’s cut
off again by this rampant beam jumping on
him again proclaiming he loves chainsaws.
Anyway obviously Makima was obviously doing
her best to lie there and it implied that
Denji and his Chainsaws reminded beam of his
GOD..
The Chainsaw Devil from the past.
Later on we end up getting a bit of information
relating directly to Pochita’s original
abilities.
So remember the battle where Reze and the
Typhoon Devil were laying waste to the city
(which if im also not wrong is the same time
in the series where our new girl Asa Mitaka
saw her mother die right infront of here eyes
by the debris that were sent flying around.
Anyways after the typhoon shows up to help
out Reze Angel realizes that Beam knows about
the original Chainsaw Devil and asks him to
spit out any information about him to help
Denji better understand his powers.
Everyone's favorite shark who’s like that's
my lord chainsaw he’s the badass-est explains
that the Chainsaw lord of the past was ultra
fast, but when he moves he uses more than
just feet.
Instead he used the chainsaw chains to hook
into things to swing between structures like
a chainsaw spider man.
Denji who hears this plain as day explanation
somehow misinterprets it.
He thinks that he needs to use his own powers
to move, so in the wildest move and while
beam is just hyping him up calling him a genius
he commands his shark friend to fully transform.
Then mounting beam like the stallion he is,
Denji screams that he gotta break beam in
with his chain and ride him like a gawdammn
horse.
Everyone hilariously reacts to this random
change asking beam if this was correct and
beam who’s probably just like omg my god
is on my back instantly screams that this
is correctio.
Again we skip forward in the series to the
next point that we get another mention of
Pochita or specifically something that effects
him more than Denji.
So due to Reze and Denji's fight being caught
on TV, the entire world now knows that Denji
or Pochita more specifically are in Japan.
Makima uses the idea that hybrids like Denji
are an extremely valuable asset to specific
countries and thats why they want to capture
him, when in all reality its most likely that
they know about the true chainsaw man and
are actually sending assassins to Japan in
order to prevent Makima from having the control
she wants over the Chainsaw Devil's heart.
Makima obviously doesn't want them to steal
away Pochita, so she ends up cancelling the
trip they had planned to instead force Denji
to be put under a 24 hours watch to make sure
he doesn't die.
This obviously leaves our boy disappointed
as he was extremely hyped to get away from
Tokyo and spend some time with Makima because
this he later ends up getting extremely depressed
as he begins wondering who exactly Pochita
is to begin with, and why does everyone wanted
his heart.
So if you've seen my entire story video for
part one, you all know what happens to Denji
and everyone in hell throughout the international
assassination arc.
After returning, it extremely effects Powers
mentality to the point where she’s unable
to even do anything by herself over fear of
the darkness devil showing up and killing
her.
To keep her calm, Denji ends up going to the
toilet with her, constantly reminding her
she's okay and even bathing with her so that
power doesn't freak out while she's alone.
This all culminates in an extremely important
moment for the duo where Power offers Denji
some of her blood as an apology for making
him miss out on his trip with Makima.
Even though they don't realize it at the time
what happens here is so damn important in
the overall story.
While drinking her blood, Denji internally
thinks to Pochita, telling him on how he always
thought naughty things would feel better the
more you know your partner.
But even though he knows Power extremely well,
this just doesn't feel hot at all.
He thinks that it probably isn't that you
should learn anything and everything there
is to know, but instead that there are some
things you have to know and some that are
better off unknown.
In that moment he casts off the idea of ever
opening that mysterious door he always see’s
in his dreams.
With Aki being the oldest in the group, over
time he began to take this big brother role
and with him being unable to protect his little
family, he became extremely distressed about
the possibility of both of them dying in the
upcoming operation to defeat the Gun Devil.
Aki who’s just trying to keep them safe,
asks Kishibe to quit the operation along with
Denji and Power, surprising Kishibe, who expected
Aki to be the one most eager for the event.
However after the group later meets with the
Minecraft hoe herself mummy Makima Aki ends
up getting persuaded to continue in the operation
as either way she was going to force Denji
and Power into going on the mission by simply
changing them from div 4 to division 7.
Later, the Future Devil who’s Aki’s new
Devil appears after he was called out to,
(btw just if there is any confusion, if Aki
was to continue using the needle weapon he
had before, his life span would run out leaving
him unable to complete his own mission of
killing the Gun devil.
Plus the Fox devil he used earlier in the
series gapped it and doesn't talk to him anymore
due to it getting damaged in the Katana Man
battle.
Anyways the future Devil who rises up by the
window sends an ominous vision to Aki, stating
that both him and Power will end up being
slaughtered by Denji in a completely and absolutely
unavoidable future.
After this THE DEVIL THAT DEVILS FEAR MOST
SHALL, foreshadowing Pochita's return in the
future.
So I should probably quickly explain what
happens to Aki while he’s out with Makima.
As
the Gun devil approaches her taking out thousands
and thousands of people Aki, Makima and Angel
all wait by a church for him.
Once he gets within shooting distance, Makima
instantly shoots these chains out of her which
pierce thru both Aki and Angel taking their
abilities and adding them to her arsenal along
with the abilities from the punishment Devil,
Snake Devil and Spider Devil.
Im assuming this didnt instantly kill Aki
or angel and wasn't apart of the vision Aki
was given.
After Makima does some sorta craziness making
this portal appear above the Gun devil she
then goes ahead and off screens the freaking
dude.
like I wish we got to see what happened exactly,
most likely though Makima just went demon
mode and them took apart of the Gun Devil
and merged it with Aki turning him into the
Gun fiend.
Sadly due to Aki being merged off screen with
the Gun devil the, Future Devil's prediction
eventually comes true as Denji is forced to
kill Aki in an attempt to save his one remaining
family member and best friend.
Yet as we all know that doesn't exactly work
out and Denji who gave up his emotions to
Makima was unable to prevent Power's death.
To top it off on all of the days she could've
been merked, she was killed infront of our
boys eyes on his birthday, while she held
his cake in her hands.
Left in a crippling depressive state, Denji
asks Makima if it was all dream, unable to
comprehend why she would suddenly do something
like that.
Makima then reveals that she wanted to bring
Pochita back since the very beginning, however
she was unable to do so because he had to
stay sealed as Denji's heart due to the promise
between them.
Left with no other choice, she quickly planned
a way to break try and break Denji's will
and inturn the promise.
Makima explains that the promise he made with
Pochita was infact a contract, one that Pochita
would remain as Denji's heart as long as Denji
fulfilled his dreams of living a normal life.
Thus, Makima went around planning a normal
life for Denji, making him live with Aki and
Power in the hopes that they would become
like a family to and make that happiness his
new normal.
Then once that was set in place she would
destroy the whole thing, any form of happiness
or sadness from this point on would be solely
crafted by her in a tactic to manipulate him
ever further as she believes its time that
he atone for Pochita’s previous sins.
Finally, in a moment that im not even sure
if its true or not to this day, she reveals
that Denji infact killed his own father and
manipulates him into believing that he was
a horrible person because of his patricide
and therefore did not deserve to live his
dream of having a normal life...
Hearing this over and over again, it flashes
into Denji's dream world where he’s still
a child and ends up agreeing with her as he
now has just been gaslighted into believing
it was true.
Then with that finally complete Makima successfully
breaks Denji's contract with Pochita, leaving
the boy on the couch in a completely unresponsive
state.
The day after, Makima walks alongside a catatonic
Denji in a hallway filled with all of Tokyo's
Special Division 4 Devils and Fiends.
Makima then reveals that every single one
of them were followers of the original Chainsaw
Devil in hell, and that they were all waiting
for his "resurrection".
Being caught off guard an unexpected explosion
goes off blowing up the side of the building
and showing the the absolute g himself big
teacher Kishibe has brought in an entire division
to kill Makima.
In combination with this first move a few
of his other top agents then begin summoning
the Hell Devil to earth in an attempt to trap
Makima and send her back to hell.
However, Makima suddenly enlists the help
of Chainsaw Man, forcing Pochita to take over
Denji's catatonic body.
This is obviously now due to the fact that
the promise or contract was just broken, marking
the fateful return of the original Chainsaw
Man who technically now controls Denji’s
body.
Pochita quickly disposes of the Hell Devil,
turning him into a couple bits of hell devil
shichimi.
Honestly such a clean panel, always loved
this one, where you finally see the Full Chainsaw
Man form for the first time..
Anyways a remaining agent uses himself to
revive the hell devil back, telling him to
die once he finishes his job.
Yet for some random reason it doesn't attack
Makima and instead slaps down on Pochita as
if he’s some sort of bug, casting him back
into hell.
Soon after after arriving there, Pochita is
greeted by hordes of devils that attack him
over and over.
However they are simply no match for the original
Chainsaw Man, as he quickly defeats them one
by one effortlessly.
Meanwhile, Makima reveals to Kishibe the true
power of the Chainsaw Man and why people either
worship of fear him.
Pochita is able to erase a devil's existence
and the concept they represent by eating them,
even now Makima remembers the battles themselves
but the names have started to fade.
Its shown that a confused Kishibe doesn't
even know what the Nazi’s regime was or
that chainsaw man has already erased things
from the world like aids, world war 2, nukes,
the light of a specific start that breaks
a childs mind, the four other conclusions
other than death at the end of life and much
much more have already been erased from existence
by the chainsaw man.
Mummy Makima explains that her goal is that
she’s planning to fight him in order to
defeat and control his power with the aim
of erasing concepts that she deems unnecessary
for humankind to create a better world.
Kishibe then asks her if she's not afraid
of losing, which she responds by saying that
she wouldn't mind being devoured by Pochita
as she is a big fan of the chainsaw man.
Which holy moly I freaking love this line,
it slaps so hard every time
Pochita, just like he did at the beginning
of the story, somehow manages to find a way
out of hell and returns to earth thru a specific
door.
Still standing with the old man, Makima continues
to reveal that Pochita will always aid those
who ask for his help, but in return he will
also kill them after the deed is done.
Therefore, since she asked for his aid, Pochita
is coming to destroy her.
She warns Kishibe to stay away and prepares
to engage Pochita, but he kills her before
she could even react.
After briefly looking at Kishibe, Pochita
hears Kobeni's call for help from far away
and runs to her location, leaving Kishibe
alone with Makima's body.
Elsewhere, at everyone's favorite a burger
joint, which I can barely show any of because
its to brutal for YOUTUBE YAY!!
Kobeni is taken aside by her new boss, who
chastises her and slaps her across the face.
Quietly Kobeni mutters "Save Me".
Obviously not realizing the consequences of
this, The staff suddenly turn to see Chainsaw
Man looming over them, greeting Kobeni with
a "Vah!"
Froom here on for a little bit Pochita kinda
half confusedly trys to accomplish a few of
his boys wishes himself, he looks at the restaurant's
menu, and remembers an earlier request from
Denji about how he wanted to try hamburgers.
Sitting at a nearby table, he attempts to
order a hamburger, speaking through a series
of chainsaw revs.
After this freaking hilarious set of terrible
coincidences where Kobeni manages to drop
his meal over and over again, her disbelieving
coworker begins to believe that the situation
is an elaborate televised prank, yet they
all end up getting yoinked by Pochita for
Kobeni’s mistakes.
Pochita eventually manages to bite down on
his floor burger but grimaces at how damn
disgusting it is.
Then in the same moment he remembers another
past wish of Denji's- to go on a date with
a girl, and tears Kobeni away from her new
job to take her out on an ice cream date.
Stopping at an ice cream van, Chainsaw Man
shreds it to pieces, before acquiring a pair
of ice creams for the cute couple.
Kobeni continues to sob, crying out that the
ice cream doesn't taste of anything, which
is probably due to the stress she's under
frying her taste buds.
FINALLY someone who can save the day appears
and threatens Chainsaw Man, but jk this dude
was just some fodder random and is instantly
eviscerated as Pochita turns Kobeni towards
the infamous Dance-Dance Mushroom machine.
Chucking her down to the ground, she orders
the terrorfied lady to dance, but Kobeni comments
she has no moneys.
Looking up though she see’s that Pochita
has already shred an ATM to bits allowing
Kobeni to get some cash and begin her terrifying
world record run.
As this happens Pochita finally leaves her
to go elsewhere.
He makes his way to a random rooftop and while
surveying his surroundings notices that Makima
is already nearby.
She comments on him noticing her, as she commands
her allies to emerge.
Suddenly, Chainsaw Man stands surrounded by
seven Devil Hunters, all commenting on their
love for Makima and desire to date her.
They each pledge their allegiance to Makima,
with Katana Man commenting she has saved their
lives "over and over again", as Makima agrees
to the bet: A date in return for whoever beats
Chainsaw Man.
As Makima stands amongst her group of Human-Devil
hybrids, she elaborates on their nature: They
are not humans; Devils or Fiends; but another
type of creature that was erased by the Chainsaw
Devil's power yet somehow continue to exist.
Pochita tho, who really couldn't care less
about her just yawns in response.
Seeing this Makima then commands her agents
to attack.
So i've just gotta chill on some aspects of
this fight here so it doesn't get restricted,
as our lil Pochita goes absolutely ham, destroying
all of these silly old hybrids.
After laying out a few of the hybrids, Pochita
leaps backwards to the safety of another building,
seeing this tho, the Whip Hybrid appears,
and slashes at him.
Her attacks are completely futile as they
seem to have little impact rather than slowing
his movement, however, as Reze blasts through
the building she grabs ahold of the slowed
Chainsaw Man, carrying him into the sky.
After completely dunking on Reze, Pochita
gets stunned in the air by a spear thrown
from the spear hybrid.
Taking this momentary daze Makima points her
hand like some crazy ass finger pistol and
says BANG over and over again to blast Chainsaw
Man up into the upper atmosphere of the earth
itself.
As Chainsaw Man is pushed out of the atmosphere
and into space, he does the most insane respawn
glitch and reaches inside of himself and rips
out a part of his own heart.
He then proceeds to fling himself towards
the ground below and as the heart of Pochita
begins to burn up upon re-entry to the atmosphere,
Chainsaw Man's body manages to quickly reform
around it.
Still falling he then does another big brain
play and unlike how Denji used the chains,
Pochita uses them correctly launching his
chains across the city, grappling onto Makima
the Whip, Flamethrower and Spear hybrids.
Then hoisting them all up into the air, they
each express a moment of shock, before they
too are torn apart by Pochita's chainsaws.
Back over with everyone's favorite Kobeni,
like these anime onlys who’re hating on
her rn are gonna do the biggest 180.
anyways her game of Dance-Dance Mushroom is
shown coming to a close.
As it finally ends, she stands there tired
and sweating atop the machine before happily
exclaiming that she got a perfect score.
Yet as her head turns to the side, her expression
turns to one of worry as she looks over at
Chainsaw Man, who's just chilling on a step
nearby watching her.
With Makima having also arrived she goes on
to state to Kobeni that in total, she has
been killed 26 times by Chainsaw Man, and
yet she questioned why it was that he continued
to refuse to eat her…
Confused how she even got involved Kobeni
shows denial but Makima quickly cuts her off,
saying that she did indeed have a major role
in the events currently unfolding, and that
her fear of Chainsaw Man had grown weaker.
This prompts Kobeni to look over at Chainsaw
Man as blood begins to leak from his body,
causing him to to collapse forwards onto the
walkway.
A television is shown in the window of a city
shop with a news broadcast being displayed,
stating that Chainsaw Man had just defeated
the Gun Devil.
He goes on to state that the news of the Gun
Devil's defeat was being met with appraise
and shock across the globe, the following
shots showing images of people thrilled and
overjoyed as they watched the broadcast on
their televisions.
With more blood is pooling around Chainsaw
Man, Makima states that the humans cheering
him on were eating away at his overall strength
and contrasting the power given to him by
all the devils who feared him.
Then Stating "Usage: 1,000 Years" a large
a black spear pushes out from one of those
weird rings Makima makes.
Instantly the faces of Kobeni are Pochita
are shown reacting to the attack, their faces
bathed in light as Makima launches the spear
at Kobeni.
Like the hero he is, Chainsaw Man moves in
front of Kobeni, pushing her away and letting
the spear pierces through his torso causing
him to immediately collapse onto the ground.
Seeing him gravely wounded, Makima sighs as
nearby the crowds continue to cheer for him,
his body laying still as the fear that once
surrounded him slowly begins to fade.
NOOWW remember when I said it was suuuper
big brain that Denji was given some of Powers
blood earlier on in the series.
Well we find ourselves inside of Pochita where
he has managed to find those last remnants
of Power.
He nudges her with his paw trying to gently
wake her up.
Turning her head towards Pochita, confused
she asks who he is before quickly making the
connection that he was Pochita, who she'd
been told about through what Denji had said
about him.
Pochita smiles at her realization before telling
her that he wanted her to save Denji.
He tells her that she wasn't truly dead, as
she was currently the blood that Denji had
drank from her before, and that if nothing
was done she would soon disappear.
Pochita asks for her to eat his flesh and
revive as a devil.
To which our girl like the freaking queen
she is happily obliges.
So like even as much as i've read this story
it still freaking confuses me at points, like
someone please let me know if they know what
it is for a fact.
But I think that after Power shoots out of
chainsaw man as the blood devil, Denji is
given control over his body again by Pochita.
As after Denji and Power have their final
conversation together in the dumpster where
Denji forms a contract with Power to come
and find her so they can be friends again
in the future, he still has Pochita’s tail
protruding from his chest.
Anyways a bunch of stuff with Denji goes down
in between him finally getting control of
his body back and making it to the fateful
day at the graveyard where Denji and Makima
have their final battle.
Obviously the Majority of this fight here
happens with Denji's POV so ill only bring
up things that relate to Pochita directly
but something I do want to point out that
is super interesting, is that three crows
are shown sitting on a few graves nearby watching
before flying up into the sky.
This here is just alluding to the other 3
foes in the four horsemen that our boy is
gonna have to defeat in the future.
Skipping more into the final battle, Makima
absolutely dunks on Denji and takes ahold
of Denji's wounded corpse from the handle
on his head then proceeeds to tear out pulling
out Pochita with her right arm, BUTTT I CANT
SHOW THAT CAUSE YOUTUBE IS FREEAKING CRAZY
WITH CHAINSAW MAN.
Like im not tryna bring light to the savageness
of the story but the absolutely brilliant
writing that Tatsuki Fujimoto has brought
up with this story.
Anyways As she slowly pulls Pochita from his
body, she tells Denji that even when she used
nothing but her bare fists he still lost to
her, and that he was not nearly as strong
as Chainsaw Man.
She asks how she could possibly get him to
completely give up on living, and how she
could ever possibly get Chainsaw Man back.
Denji responds by not talking and instead
spitting on her face causing Makima to get
angry and rage out responding by telling him
that Chainsaw Man did not spit in people's
faces.
No he was far far different, Chainsaw Man
also didn't wear clothes or even speak and
that he only made a mess out of everything
he did.
She says that even with all of Denji's ignorance,
he was still chosen as Chainsaw Man which
puzzles her, but now since he was standing
between the two of them, he must die.
After Makima for some bizarre reason thinks
she has killed and taken out the protag this
Aki wannabe lights up a smoke before literally
coughing her own lungs out.
Quickly she puts out the smoke realizing that
she cant handle the heat and instead picks
up Pochita, telling him that it was now the
second time she had ever defeated him.
She explains that he now belongs to her and
that they'd be together forever, that they'd
eat a lot together, sleep together, and live
a happy life together forever.
Several feet behind Makima, Denji though who
isn't actually dead slowly stands up from
amongst a pile of corpses now wearing an oversized
Public Safety uniform.
He quietly walks over to Makima, and as she
starts to notice him, he pulls out a chainsaw
and slices her down the chest.
Confused and shocked Makima gasps, as she
begins to fall to her knees, Denji in a role
reversal from before now stands directly above
her.
Reaching down, Denji picks up Pochita, he
then exclaims that hell be taking his boy
back and says that what he did just now was
dangerous, and that he had used up all of
the blood Power had given him from their contract.
Hence why I mentioned the stuff with the dumpster
earlier.
Makima, now in a spot she never expected to
be in, asks how Denji was alive, to which
also remember how Pochita ripped out a portion
of his heart and threw it to the ground.
WELL that was who Makima was actually fighting
the whole time and Denji just vaguely remembered
how to fight like that, so yeah…
SOOOO with the Power chainsaw running amok
inside of Makima she was caught off guard
and unable to move.
Some absolutely mental stuff that happens
after this that only involves a van, one full
fridge and Denji’s stomach, but there is
one final huge moment in the series where
the cute lil Pochita makes another appearance.
so skipping forward to after we meet the new
control devil because for those of you unsure,
due to Denji munching Makima back in the way
he did it didnt result in her being erased
from existence but instead it was almost a
way to get around her uncanny contract with
the Japanese prime minister.
Anyways After falling asleep in bed with Nayuta
Denji begins to dream with the dog sleeping
with him now being replaced by Pochita.
Within the dream a young Denji opens his eyes
and finds himself holding Pochita as the two
sit within the shed they used to live in.
Pochita tells Denji that his dream was to
be hugged by someone, but his strength always
made it hard for anyone to want to
hug him.
Pochita realizes it sounds kinda crazy, but
ensures him he wasn't lying.
He then thanks Denji for making his dream
finally come true.
Pochita then asks Denji if he could fulfill
the Control Devil's dream too, as she's always
dreamt of building equal relationships with
other people.
The control devil has always had this dream,
but couldn't accomplish it since she only
knew how to form relationships through the
power of fear, and because of that, she grew
yearning for something like a family over
time.
Pochita tells Denji that now he wanted him
to make that dream come true for Nayuta, to
which Denji asks Pochita how he was supposed
to do that and our lovable chainsaw man tells
him to give her lots and lots of hugs.
so that there officially brings us to the
very end of waters but cheater's life everything
that is kind of given to us that relates to
him specifically throughout part one of the
story obviously if you guys have enjoyed this
video and want to watch more stuff just like
this then let me know who you want me to go
over in the future if it'd be like Aki or
say Makima's full life throughout the story
then I'll go and cover that because at least
you know we have everything from their life
specifically so far in this story as well
that I can go over in huge detail including
like Aki's background from when he was a childhood
which is extremely extremely important and
the overall narrative with him and dingy and
them like becoming Brothers in a sort of way
absolutely love like Howard ends up fleshing
out between the two of them and the final
like battle that ends up going down sorry
to spoil any of you anime only that are here
but you know it's an absolutely amazing battle
that sadly results in the death of his brother
Aki so if you guys want me to go over there
then let me know down in the comment section
below and I'll be sure to do that in the future
obviously though if you are new around here
I want to watch more stuff just like this
then make sure you hit that subscribe button
and also be sure to leave a like on the video
as helps out with pushing my content to a
bunch of new amazing people and if you want
earlier access to my videos like two days
before they go live on YouTube then be sure
to check out my Patreon down on the link below
which I will leave there for all of you but
for now it's been your professional degenerate
Diavolo and I will see you all in a bit bye